you're the first person i've talked to
talk you know i've heard this many times
but tell me about what happens when you
do this drug
i mean crystal meth uh whenever you do
it man it just it's like
you can you can [ __ ] forever i ain't
gonna lie i mean it's like non-stop we
can [ __ ] for like
from seven and seven pm to seven a.m and
just be like happy to go lucky still
full of energy
going hard i mean not even stopping to
smoke a cigarette it's like
just smoking cigarette while we're at it
and you've seen my old lady she's
beautiful i mean
who wouldn't want to go you know what i
mean so i mean yeah
all right lee yeah lee uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
i'm originally from right here in west
virginia layland
i was born and raised i've been ever
since i was born i've been on layla
mountain i really never moved off
and tell me about your your family he
was uh uh my mom she's
my stepdad he's the preacher at the
church he passed away just not too long
ago my mom
she uh she runs the danny's community
building out there where we live she's
kind of
that kind of end of the community with
everybody i'm
kind of a religious family yeah i never
followed into it but
like they was my mom she's all about it
and my stepdad he was all about it
but i kind of was the relent like
never followed into it right how would
you describe your childhood
i was it was hit miss i was kind of on
my own from like
i'd say 17 and up i just kind of did my
own thing like i
kind of went out left mom and went and
hung out with my buddies and
did everything else and then after after
i found out how rough it was i kind of
went back to my grandma's house man i
just
i got an rv up there i've lived and i've
moved in it
and i've been doing things from there
yeah appalachia is a tough life for a
young man right
yeah sure finding work yeah you got that
right there ain't nothing around here to
be done
if you ain't if you ain't logging and
you ain't doing uh
uh some kind of power or welding or
something like that there's nothing
really for you i mean it's kind of
slow it's slow thing the coal mines have
dried up yeah ain't nobody doing no coal
mining harley
yeah how far did you go in school i went
all the way up to 11th grade and
uh my baby mom and she got pregnant with
my little boy and
i dropped out because i had to go try to
figure out something to
kind of support everybody else with i
went from that i went over to working at
the
sawmill over here in beckley i worked
there for i'd say
almost three years went from that to
working at the turkey farms over in
lewisburg
i worked there at avign for almost
i'd say three years there and uh
from there on i mean i've kind of just
went into working for myself
and working for a guy doing mobile
detail
how do you support yourself today i'm
doing landscaping
i do a lot of landscaping i got a vacuum
you drag behind your lawnmower and you
you go it sucks up all the leaves the
acorns and everything else out your
people's yards and i go over to the rich
part of the neighborhood and i drag it
around behind my lawnmower and i do a
couple yards and i can make pretty good
money doing it
that's great you're working are drugs
part of your life they have been yeah i
was i was pretty well strung out
i was big on the ice and i was i did i
got into heroin for a little bit but
here recently i've i've kind of got
straightened out a little bit i've been
in the suboxone program and it's been
doing me really really good actually
that's great that's great
and what what age were you when you
started with drugs i was
i'd say i was probably 14. and drugs
drugs are a big deal for
everyone out here yeah it's everybody i
mean anybody you run into is either done
or
is on them like the people you went to
school with how many of them got into
drugs
actually most of the people i mean a lot
of people i went to school with are
really dead
i mean a lot of people died from heroin
man heroin's dropped everybody it's
crazy how many people
are the fentanyl in the heroin the
fentanyl yeah the fentanyl it's dropping
everybody i was just
i think it was yesterday i found out my
good buddy john parker he was
he just he just died from it they found
him dead actually at his house
that's happened many times yeah it's
crazy how often it happens really
what keeps you here in appalachia i just
uh you know that's a good question be
honest i mean
i don't know why i stay there's so many
so few opportunities and
there's so many reasons to leave i think
it's just that my family's here and i
just i'm
relentless to run off and leave them i
mean my grandma she needs me right now i
stay up on the mountain with her all the
time and
she's got diabetes and she's got the
where she came something out of her mind
but she can't remember she leaves a
stove on
i'm just paranoid if i actually was to
get up and leave her
if she wouldn't leave the stove and burn
the house down or something like that
you know what i mean
and you got a nice girlfriend yeah and i
got a beautiful old lady
yeah that's a fact but if i was to leave
she'd leave with me
yeah you and sam should probably think
about what you could do other than
staying here especially if she gets your
kid back
yeah no doubt
have you traveled have you been to other
parts of the country i haven't been to
other parts of the country i've been out
the state i've been to like north
carolina and i've been uh
south carolina myrtle beach
uh maryland nothing major not not too
far off
what are the best things about living
out here
there's some good things it's beautiful
the it's i mean it is it's beautiful and
i mean you got wildlife and where i live
at man i live so far back in the country
there's really not nobody else i mean we
don't live on top of each other like out
there in the city everybody lives right
dead on top of each other
where i live at my closest neighbor is
like half a mile up the road you know
what i mean how many acres do you have
my family owns like 114.
i'm still in the top of the mountain
it's actually in the middle of the new
river national forest the only people
own anything around us is the park
service the park owns everything that my
family don't own
so we're back there they we could pretty
much almost gate it off to where
only only our family could get back here
but really it's right now it's open
because people can go back and hunt park
service
yeah it's it's spectacularly beautiful
yes that's that's a fact
so the most beautiful land in the
country yeah i mean if you if you've
been up here to grand view right above
where you are at right now and you go up
there and you can get a turkey spur and
you look over
if you look off a turkey spur straight
across and you look over on the mountain
you're actually looking at the mountain
that my family owns over there
what kind of wildlife you have here uh
we got bears we got
they they say there ain't panthers but
there is a pant there is panthers big
big cats i mean we got uh coyotes we got
bobcats we've got rabbits i mean
we got rattlesnakes and we got
copperheads it's you name it
it's i've seen a little bit of
everything around here be honest and
then stuff like that
yeah we got the deer we got they say we
got elk i haven't seen any elk
but they say that they released elk but
i haven't seen anything
but where we live at the the bear the
park service is so bad about
catching all these nuisance bears over
here in the city limits and they gotta
they got to take them and release them
somewhere so they bring them over there
where we live at because we're in the
middle of nowhere and they release them
and then they become a nuisance to us
and they're up there in our trash and
everything
else in the night time you should see
and sam the other night whenever this
this big old it's like something was out
there in the field i couldn't tell you
exactly what it was but all of a sudden
we was laying there sleeping and all of
a sudden it was just screaming it was
crazy screaming i was like what is that
i was like woke me up it was screaming
loud
i was like what is that and it was like
something out there got attacked by
something in the yard right beside the
house it was like so close it scared the
[ __ ] out of both those
it was crazy yeah you're in the wild
here what uh
what do you think got you into this
situation you're in with addiction and
all that is do you think it was the
environment was it something in your
childhood was it
uh i think it was i think the main thing
was because there wasn't nothing else to
do
yeah i hear that a lot because i mean
like there really ain't nothing to keep
you i mean like
you get high past his time and then and
i mean that's really i mean that's
that's i can't say that there's too many
other reasons other than i mean yeah
after i did it a couple times i like the
high
and it kind of just kept it rolling
but whenever i got in ice i didn't get
addicted to ice
i got addicted to the sex that me and my
lady had on ice
that's what it was addictive it wasn't
the ice had done it for me it was the
the seven eight hours non-stop going at
it doing that that's what got me strong
in my eyes
and that was the only time i like i'd go
get it and i knew exactly what time it
was when i got home
you know what i mean so it was usually
you're the first person i've talked to
talking i've heard this many times but
tell me about what happens when you do
this drug
i mean crystal meth uh whenever you do
it man it just it's like
you can you can [ __ ] forever i ain't
gonna lie i mean it's like non-stop we
can [ __ ] for like
from seven and seven pm to seven a.m and
just be like happy go lucky still full
of energy going
hard i mean not even stopping to smoke a
cigarette it's like
just smoking cigarette while we're at it
and you've seen my old lady she's
beautiful i mean who wouldn't want to go
you know what i mean
so i mean yeah i guess
she was she was part of my addiction
and and you'll do you'll stay up for how
many days
i could i'm bad i'm better i crashed in
three days three days i'm out it's over
with
a lot of people they can stay sam should
stay up a lot longer than me but three
days it's
i'm laying down i could do a big old
shot of it and i'm still
i'm laying down regardless i'm falling
out yeah but some people say it for
yeah some people they get i've heard
people been up a week in
two weeks i'm like i don't even know how
they're doing they're talking about
shadow people walking by them and stuff
and i'm like yeah you need to lay down
bub
been up too long crazy drug yes it is
has people outside flashlights three or
four o'clock in the morning just looking
around outside
it's like man you know the neighbor's
child yeah
what the what's what's your biggest fear
man my biggest fear is losing my family
be honest i think that's my biggest fear
really
you mean your fam your yeah like not not
so much
my not so much my parents like my little
girl sam
they're mainly my family really i mean
like it comes down to it my grandma
my old lady and sam that's my baby
that's that's my family
yeah i don't really include my mom
because i mean i love my mom don't get
me wrong but i mean like when it comes
down to absolute people i gotta have
it's my old lady and my grandma because
i worry about my grandma so much that i
gotta keep her around me right
what's the most important lesson you've
learned how old are you i'm 30.
yeah what's the most important lesson
you've learned
ah i mean the most important lesson i've
learned it probably had to be
stopped it definitely had to be stopped
choosing drugs over
my over family i mean for real i mean
because i [ __ ] my family over so many
times for drugs it's [ __ ]
and they've took me back like every time
so yeah that's what's the worst kind of
stuff you would do
steal money out of her purse uh
i've uh overdrafted a bank account
you're on high huh your mom yeah my
grandma
your grandma yeah i've done it to my
grandmother and my mom i stole her i
stole her pistols
sold the pistols for the dope uh
uh stole their cars on numerous
occasions it's not that you
have these terrible ethics it's that the
drug makes you so crazy that you'll do
it yeah
so it's like man if i you know yeah yeah
yeah it's like i mean
i mean i me yeah back in the day i may
have been like yeah i'm still mom's
truck and go run around for a little bit
but i mean i wasn't out doing nothing
crazy but whenever you're on that drugs
man you're like man i gotta go get this
dope if i gotta go get this dope and
feel like [ __ ] and i ain't feeling like
[ __ ] today
so you're like [ __ ] it i'm grabbing the
keys and i'm out
regardless whether she knows you're
doing it or not you're still doing it
it's like your morals go out the window
yeah it's just like it's
tough [ __ ] i'm leaving
have you done prison time no i know how
to do prison but i've been i've been in
regional
numerous times it's a jail yeah
southern regional back here right behind
us right yeah right next to it
yeah i've been there on domestic
domestic battery domestic assault
destruction of property brandishing a
weapon
uh possession uh
possession of narcotics uh you name it
i've been there i've been there about
15 times all together it's all over
idiotic stupid stuff like stuff i
shouldn't have never even been doing to
begin with
but it was drugs was the yeah what was
it behind it all
yeah like i mean i started smoking pot
but the pot kind of just i mean like the
pot got to a point where i just went and
i wasn't what i wanted to do anymore and
like somebody's like hey man
you're like you like upwards and i'm
like what's an upper he's like he's like
try some of this
so i tried it and i i really didn't do
too much for me so i really didn't care
much about it but then me and sam
she wanted me to shoot it and i was like
all right well i'll let you do it i was
like don't mess me up so i stuck my arm
around she shot me with it and he like
brought me to life like i mean i was
like
fully wound up could i mean i could run
a mile and like a heartbeat you know i
mean it was like it was nothing
i was like hell yeah i like it and then
from that minute on it went into sex and
like i told you
that's that's why that's what got me on
it really yeah
what's helped you the most
in terms of getting your life straight
suboxone
yeah suboxone's helped us out a lot that
and the
the fact that me and her on the same
page about getting her daughter back
yeah
because we're both pushing for the same
thing we know if we [ __ ] up that both of
us are gonna [ __ ] up and ain't just one
of us [ __ ] up
if i [ __ ] up she [ __ ] up so we can't we
can't afford for it we got if it goes
one if it goes to the south it's going
to go all the way south so we can't have
it so we're just trying to ride the
straightener to get our little girl back
good for you all right well thank you so
much for talking with me man i
appreciate y'all man i wish you the best
of luck
yep thanks
you